the Midwest is like southern Canada
right Tater Tot hot dish this is just
shepherd's pie with tater tots hon Todd
this is awesome it looks like it should
already be in my stomach already but
it's on my plate just like no concern
for whether it's healthy or good for you
they're just like these things are good
throw them in I think this is what
people from like Europe think that we
eat all the time in America
I wouldn't think immediately oh this is
a home cooked like traditional dish I
would think that this was picked up at
the jack-in-the-box like as a munching
meal I'm loving it now I get back in a
few hours for two lows Chicago style hot
dog
wow there's a lot going on right now
that is what I call a very fancy looking
hot dog chili pepper pickle tomato mmm
this whole thing Cincinnati chili papa
we have pasta here - it's like chilly
but not chilly would I eat this yes for
sure
I mean this is kind of a take off in
Chile right this isn't a true chili into
this this one wins for me Ohio your
first place right now Jimmy John's I've
heard the name Jimmy Johnson
this looks like your your basic sandwich
first thing I'm gonna say this bread
looks like garbage like if I walked into
a Quiznos and got this bread I'd be like
Quiznos what are you doing you're
keeping me out I do like that the bread
isn't overwhelming
they basically crust the bread but they
keep the crust that's a mistake on a
good time so every sandwich place needs
to get on Jimmy John's level and carve
out that extra bread your cheese soup
beer cheese soup here too soon this is
like the fever dream of a frat boy
cheese and beer this is a drunk
Wisconsin invention if I've ever seen
one
now I can really taste that beer it's
like beer cheese can you get drunk off
of this dish I'd like somebody just like
took like American cheese and PBR was
like is a beer soup it's like this is a
good drunk uncle in Serbia I get it you
got a ton of cheese laying around but
like don't do it
Wisconsin go home here Josh my overall
impression and foods from the Midwest is
that everything is delicious very savory
a lot of mixtures I didn't think there
would be good food there and I'm really
sorry about that felt very American and
sometimes you gotta feel American
because you're American people who are
watching this
America the Midwest is just kind of that
like here's here's one coast and here's
the other and we're just kind of hanging
in the middle it's like the belly of the
country if you just like rub the belly
that's